[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday september 23rd
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor
on this week's show
america britain and australia have
signed the orcas pact forming a new
alliance in the pacific and promising to
share technology for nuclear submarines
i'll be speaking to our political editor
james forsyth about whether britain
could end up in a war for taiwan former
ni6 chief john sawyers about while this
is the right approach to countering
china and former aussie prime minister
tony abbott about why australia's
approach to beijing is so different from
that of its neighbor new zealand
gas prices are rising the wholesale cost
of gas has risen 250 since january and
from the 1st of october when the price
cap is reviewed consumers will have to
pay why has this happened what should
the government do
and what will they do
we'll speak to martin lewis from money
saving experts
then we'll return to covert the history
of the pandemic is already being written
with books about the last two years now
being published if you feel like
reliving it already
kate andrews our economics editor
reviewed one adam chooses shut down for
this week's magazine and she will be on
the show with the economist steve keane
to discuss how coronavirus has changed
the way we look at the world economy and
we'll finish at cambridge university
stephen toot the vice chancellor has
announced he'll be stepping down in
september next year his time in office
has been marred by battles over free
speech and disputes about china's
involvement at the institution douglas
murray our associate editor will tell us
why he's glad to see the back of him
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and why not also subscribe to the
spectator magazine you can get 10 weeks
of the magazine delivered to your door
plus a bottle of pims worth 25 pounds
for just 10 pounds to take up the deal
just go to
www.spectator.com uk forward slash tv
offer hurry as it's only available why
stocks last
first up america britain and australia
have signed a new security pact orcus to
provide nuclear-powered submarines to
australia in his cover piece for the
week's magazine james forsythe says this
new special relationship is here to stay
he joins me now
james in your cover piece you say that
the orcas pact outlines the next 30
years of british foreign policy can you
explain
i think what the orcas pack means is
it's the decisive shift from the uk
to uh joining the effort to check china
um it was only uh six years ago that xi
jinping was having the red carpet rolled
out for him in london uh
banquet at buckingham palace a visit to
checkers a cyber security agreement
signed in of all things signed in in
downing street
the uk has now joined uh this or
play a key role in the formation of this
new alliance and it's very hard to see
this new alliance being about anything
other than trying to check china's rise
in in the asia pacific
and i think that is and i think that
because of the the the cooperation that
it puts in place on both a military and
a technological level i think this means
that this will now become the default of
uk foreign policy much in the way that
nato membership was throughout the cold
war
and james we've heard a lot about the
special relationship even if boris
johnson isn't a fan of the term
um we've also heard about difficulties
in joe biden's relationship with boris
johnson obviously they've two have been
meeting this week do you think this pact
shows the relationship is strong or in
fact the relationship survives beyond
personalities
well i think one of the strengths of the
special relationship is because it's set
up is this kind of institutional
military and intelligence cooperation
you know
the the good relations between the
political principles is is the cherry on
top of the relationship rather than the
cake itself you know and look yes their
special relationship was particularly
strong under margaret bachmann ronald
reagan but it also survived uh when the
president and prime minister really
didn't get on think of bill clinton and
john major or donald trump and and
theresa may and i think that the age of
his orcas pact will be the same it's not
going to be dependent on personal
chemistry between the u.s president and
and these two prime ministers i think in
terms of boris johnson and joe biden i
think we should have a a note of caution
here remember at the g7 summit in
cornwall everyone said oh joe biden is
going to read boris johnson the riot act
on the protocol emmanuel macron went out
of his way to look like he was kind of
more chummy with joe biden than boris
johnson was yet it was at that meeting
of the g7 but boris johnson scott
morrison and joe biden came up with this
this pack this awkward factory and that
set in motion
at that summit and so i think i think we
should i think we should be slightly
careful of some of the reports about the
nature of the relationship they have
clearly decided to do this together and
it is i think it is i think it is both a
deepening and a broadening of a special
relationship i think it takes a special
relationship into the indo-pacific and
the addition of australia um provides
you know another element to this this is
this is now a three-way special
relationship
and james can you explain
why boris johnson has chosen to be part
of this pact because when it comes to
china we've often seen tory back benches
very hawkish
going for a much tougher line than boris
johnson wants and actually he is almost
seen as a relative
xenophile when it comes to his party
yeah i think i think when laura johnson
was elected as prime minister a few
people have had him down as a as a china
hawk i think some things have changed
that
one is uh
china is no longer uh
biding its time and hiding its
capabilities it's been very clear about
its wish to create uh relationships of
either dependence or coercion and i
think it's treatment of australia after
australia called for independent
inquiries for the origins of coronavirus
has woken a lot of people up i would add
including the prime minister including
boris johnson
to
how china will behave you know australia
develops this this very vibrant trade
relationship with china china account
for a third of australia's trade china
then tried to use that to turn the screw
on australia it's going to force it into
life i think that had an impact
i think if you look at hong kong you
know china
has treaty obligations from the treaty
at simon the uk before the handover it
is trampling over all of them and it's
clamped down on
on on freedoms there
and i also think this
the pacific is where the future is being
forged in in in strategic terms in
technological terms in economic terms
this pact gives the uk a relevance in
the pacific that it has not had for
decades
now you mentioned taiwan and we've heard
some tories including theresa may the
former prime minister um suggests that
this pact could actually lead the uk
being part of a war involving taiwan and
how likely do you think there's a
possibility as a possibility
in the medium term i think this decade
is dangerous i am very persuaded by the
american academic hal brown's argument
that the danger of china
is that like willowman germany in the
right to world war one or imperial japan
in the 1940s it can see that its rise is
slowing you know china's growth rate is
halved since uh
2007.
and it sees that it ha and it can also
see a series of alliances being put in
place not just uh orcas but also for
quad which is japan india australia and
the us which which are going to check it
and contain it and decides that it has a
closing window to decisively change the
balance of power and attempts to do that
through seizing taiwan i mean the danger
is that china is buoyed by all of these
reports about how uh u.s military war
games show them losing a conflict over
taiwan but china begins to believe some
of his own propaganda about how
afghanistan shows that the u.s doesn't
have uh the stomach for the fight and
decides that it is going to try and
break out and take taiwan i think in
those circumstances uh
no
no u.s president would have really have
a choice but to defend taiwan for his
taiwan were to fall to the chinese then
that would be the end of the us-led
world order so i think there is a risk i
think the risk is at its highest in the
next uh 10 years or so i think if we get
to the end of this decade and then i
think it will become clearer
that the alliance structures that the us
are putting in place means that china um
can't hope to um to kind of gain control
of the pacific uh but i think in the
next decade are going to the next decade
is going to be quite alarming at times
and in that scenario james you mentioned
that the u.s or any u.s president would
choose to retaliate um to intervene do
you think that this pact shows that in
that
event you'd also have australia in the
uk by america's side
i i think you would certainly have
australia by the us's side but by did
its geographic uh position uh i i think
that the i think ultimately for the uk a
vital uk national interest would be at
stake which is you know
a chinese-led world order would not be a
comfortable place for the united kingdom
i mean i i think that depending on on
where u.s uk military assets are at the
time uh this could be over very quickly
though now james while we have you here
um just looking more broadly at uk
politics this week i'll be heading off
to brighton for the labour party
conference um this weekend um and while
we're not there yet we have seen some
action coming from labour kirstama um
coming up for plan to change the way in
which a labour leader is selected can
you talk us through what he's trying to
do and whether he has much chance of
doing it
so kirsten wants to move away from
uh the membership-based voting system
that produced jeremy corbyn
and go back to a kind of electoral
college now this is ironic because it
used to be that labour modernizers
favored one member one vote uh while the
left of labour party favored the
electoral college system but you know
those positions have now reversed uh the
left of the party are not happy about
this uh john mcdonnell has basically
said that if he wants to do this he
should submit himself for re-election
under the old rules because he wouldn't
have been elected if he'd said that this
was what his intention was but i think
there is i think i think as you say in
the magazine this week there is a kind
of strategic rationale from starmap
behind this move which is uh
the polling that his team are looking at
shows that voters think he is different
from jeremy corbyn but they aren't sure
whether the labour party itself has
changed not and it is hard not to see
this in an attempt to engineer uh a
fight with the party that they will hope
will stamp his authority on it and
enable him to
to to to really uh to
show voters rather than just telling
them that labour is under new management
james thanks that thanks for joining us
so how serious a player can britain be
in this alliance and could we be dragged
into a conflict in taiwan so john
sawyers former head of mi6 joins me now
boris johnson said that the new alliance
is not adversarial towards china do you
think he's right
i think he's right that is not
aggressive towards china what it is it's
a defensive alliance uh and in many ways
it's china that has been expanding its
military footprint building out in the
south china sea reaching into the indian
and pacific oceans
as it expands its uh its military
capabilities
and i think the australians are right to
be concerned about having the capacity
to push back against china uh so it's a
it's support for a wider defense
arrangement rather than being assertive
or aggressive against any particular
country but clearly china is the main
country of concern
and what does the uk bring to the
arrangement uh because clearly we're
talking about where australia is why
australia want this and the us is a
bigger partner so what is the uk's role
in all this
well it's definitely the case that the
as the french have pointed out that the
uk is the is the third country in this
but i think we bring two things first of
all we bring a lot of defense industrial
capability um
bae systems and rolls royce have
together mastered the production of uh
nuclear-propelled submarines and i think
the
they may well benefit quite
substantially from the contracts that
flow from this but i think more
importantly there's um the sort of
historic role that britain played during
the cold war where our submarines
patrolled the north atlantic and
monitored the movements of
of soviet uh submarines i think
australia could play a similar role in
the next decades in the great power
rivalry between the united states and
china as the as the uk played during the
cold war so there's a historic role
there as well
and of course the three countries are
linked together by a very high degree of
trust uh embedded in our common
experience our common culture
and uh represented in some ways by the
five ice intelligence arrangements of
which the uh uh united states uk and
australia are the three uh uh most
significant powers so i think there's a
trust element here that brings these
three countries together
and on that uh trust adamant uh we have
seen this week the diplomatic row
continue to play out in terms of france
um the exclusion of france from this
deal and also the fact that they then
lost out on a
multi-billion pound deal for
submarines why do you think france
hasn't been brought in and do you think
there's a role where uh you could see
emmanuel macron playing a more more of a
part in this
france is a significant player uh
including in the asia pacific as the uk
is but the the main countries of asia
are not looking to france to counter
balance china they're looking to the
united states to do so and it's not a
question of a contract over a few years
it's a it's an arrangement which will
last decades uh and i don't think
frankly france has built up the level of
trust um uh
with uh asian countries with australia
and so on uh that the united states and
the uk brings
so france has got a role to play uh i do
think the uh the maiden administration
mishandled the french dimension but
equally i think the french reaction has
been frankly over the top and you know
they've been throwing their toys out of
the pram they will get over it uh but
the uh
it's also a rather dramatic example of
diplomatic pyrotechnics by france but
the uk
can't just sort of
dismiss a french role
france remains our closest neighbor
and britain's defense in depth isn't in
the south china sea our defense in depth
is in western europe so getting back on
terms with our european neighbors and
partners is going to be really important
now joe biden has said that he does not
want another cold war and do you think
he's going to get a choice in that are
we potentially edging to something a bit
more like that
well what's changed katie over the last
um
10 years or so isn't the west's behavior
is china's behavior i think there was a
an opportunity under deng xiaoping and
his two successors jan jamin and hujin
tao that the china would evolve in a in
a gradually more plural way but xi
jinping has taken china back to uh to
core marxism leninism in in in the role
of the party controlling the country uh
he's re redeveloped the uh uh cult of
personality that we last saw with mao
zedong um
and uh china has become a much more
assertive and and uh uh controlling and
domineering uh country and i think what
we're seeing now is the united states
responding to chinese uh aggression and
chinese behavior now it's not the same
as the cold war because of the sheer
scale of china's economy and the fact
that china is going to play a really
important part in the global economy uh
for decades to come so it's a different
sort of
great power rivalry that we'll be
dealing with but defense and security
arrangements are going to be a crucial
part of making sure that our friends and
allies in asia are not sort of dominated
by china in the way that china would
would perhaps like
and just finally do you think we're
beginning to see a new world order and
new alliances um you mentioned five eyes
earlier um but clearly new zealand seems
to be moving in a different direction or
at least wanting to adopt a much softer
approach when it comes to china so our i
think our old allies are almost
reassessing and we're seeing new pacs
now
well i think the uk is reassessing uh
because we've left the european union um
and because
we are paying quite a price for that
france is leading the pack in some ways
in in
making our lives difficult in a in a
post-brexit world
i think the uh this government perhaps
not surprisingly has decided that
it can't just go it alone it has to be
more closely associated strategically
even more closely associated with the
united states so i think that
transatlantic alliance is likely to be
uh closer in years to come of course we
run the risk of america taking an
extreme nationalist turn which is not to
be completely ruled out in uh in years
ahead i think it unlikely but it's not
impossible um and i think the european
union in particular france needs to
reconsider how it is going to play a
role not just in the economic and
prosperity benefits of
china's rise but in ensuring a a calm
and and
secure global defense order as well so
yes some alliances are being reforged we
we can't ignore our backyard here in
europe russia remains a bigger threat to
us than any other country
and nato remains a central element for
defending ourselves against russia we
can't distract ourselves or even make
our main effort in the pacific but what
is happening in the in the western
pacific with china's rise has to be
added to the list of things that we have
to defend ourselves against and i think
the orcas agreement is an important step
in that direction
john thanks for joining us
these new submarines are going to be
based in australia a country that
already has a difficult relationship
with china why have they taken such a
different line from their neighbours new
zealand who seem to be cozying up to the
regime in beijing tony abbott the former
australian prime minister is on the show
tony thanks for joining us what does
australia get at this new alliance
we get essentially three things katie
first we get
a modern nuclear submarine
which is an incredibly important
element in any
country's
defense
obviously a nuclear-powered submarine
gives you a strategic deterrent
in a way that no conventional submarine
can so that's the first and the greatest
benefit for australia
out of this new tripartite pact with the
united kingdom and the united states
the second thing is that it brings
britain back
east of suez
in a way that britain hasn't really been
for at least
five decades and
given the challenge we all face from
china right now to have britain the
western world's second strongest
military power
back
front and center in our region is a
really positive development
third and finally it makes australia a
more significant part of the overall
western alliance if we can contribute to
along with our other armed forces uh
eight effective modern nuclear-powered
submarines
we are a force to be reckoned with and
frankly um given
our standing in the wider world i think
we should be a force to be reckoned with
and this is what will be
thanks to the orcas deal
now emmanuel macron's not very happy at
the moment um over the orcus pact and if
you had the french um
really um getting quite angry and
showing that in various ways uh
over the fact that the um contract
regarding submarines uh
was moved from them um
do you think that's something that would
worry uh the australian government uh
how is that perceived in australia
we've had periods in the past when our
relations with france went into the deep
freeze
there was a period
in the 80s when
the french were conducting nuclear tests
in the south pacific and french agents
actually sank a greenpeace vessel in
auckland harbour
i think it was in the 80s then there was
a period in the mid 90s when they
resumed
nuclear testing in the south pacific
when
our relations were pretty pretty frosty
look um france is an important country
uh it has
powerful armed forces
um
essentially
uh its strategic interests and those of
australia the united kingdom and the
united states are very similar
but the french have always
liked to stand a bit aloof
from anglos
and
um
we've never had the kind of strategic
intimacy with the french
that we've had
for really
decades and decades and decades with the
united states and the united kingdom
and given the
importance of nuclear technology
really
it's
only possible to have this kind of
relationship
with people who are your most intimate
strategic partners
um i thought
back in 2016 when the
french submarine deal was
first announced that it didn't make a
lot of sense to take an existing french
nuclear design
spend 15 years redesigning it and
rebuilding it as a conventional sub
only to give us something um
less effective than what we could have
had right now
but i don't think the french were ever
going to share with us
their nuclear technology simply
because good friends and all that they
are
they're not family in the same way that
the united states and the united kingdom
are
and just finally tony
we've had theresa may our former prime
minister warning that the orcas pact
because the uk dragged into conflict
over taiwan
do you think that's a realistic
possibility
[Applause]
look i think conflict over taiwan is a
very realistic possibility
and i think it's important that the
western world
stands
very surely
with
the people of taiwan
i'm not saying that we abandoned our
one china policy
but we should be making it absolutely
crystal clear to the china is that any
unilateral alteration of the status quo
any coercion of taiwan
will have incredibly serious
consequences let's not forget taiwan is
a liberal pluralist democracy of 25
million people it has never been part of
communist china
it hasn't really been part of china
since
1895 when it was ceded to the japanese
there was a very brief period at the end
of the second world war
when china was in chaos
when it was nominally chinese but it's
never been part of communist china
since the 80s it's been
increasingly a flourishing
liberal pluralist democracy
and
free countries wherever they are
should be standing shoulder to shoulder
with the free people of taiwan
saying that we should be the ones to
control our own destiny we should not be
subject to coercion from the commissars
in
beijing if we wish to reunite with
beijing that's got to be our decision
not
that of the beijing government thanks
tony
back home a gas price crisis has seen
energy companies collapse and means
brits be forced to pay for larger bills
no matter what the government might say
how serious is this i'm joined now by
martin lewis from money saving expert
martin first could you just explain to
viewers why gas prices have risen in the
way they have
i'm always better at the how than the
why i leave that to the business experts
have they risen we have a huge spike in
wholesale worldwide gas prices
um which means prices across the world
have gone up but the uk is far worse hit
than elsewhere for a number of factors
first of all because we're also relying
quite substantially these days as we've
got no longer have coal generation and
haven't replaced it with other forms on
a lot of gas powered electricity power
stations so our electricity costs tend
to mirror the gas wholesale price price
quite substantially
there have been issues in uh
interconnectors with europe of getting
gas across to the uk and a range of
other factors that mean uk wholesale
prices
are astronomical four-fold what they
were this time last year
and that is an enormous catastrophic hit
for the uk energy market and we're now
seeing it roll into consumers now no one
should sit there and think why did we
not know i mean i was presenting good
morning britain back in june and i asked
the energy minister i said you do
realise in october there is going to be
an enormous rise in energy prices and i
got
to be honest not very much in reply that
batted it off with talk of price caps
and switching and things like that so
this has been coming a long time not
quite to the extreme level we have now i
mean i wrote my my first recent piece on
it two weeks ago and then i called it
dire but it's got a lot worse since and
then martin we've heard from the
government uh more recently in the sense
that boris johnson is saying that this
is a temporary problem and directly
linking it to covid the fact that
everyone is almost springing back into
action and there's a surge in demand
because of that um do you think this
right to say this is a temporary issue
and it will be out of the worst of it
fairly soon or is that a bit optimistic
well he's right in the sense that life
is a temporary issue isn't it it only
lasts 80 90 odd years
so i mean of course this is temporary it
will be different in the future the
question is both how long it lasts and
what the current impact has on future
prices now my focus is on consumer
energy prices and the situation is
pretty bloody dire right now let me try
and talk you through where we are
so over 50 percent of homes pay the
price cap
the energy price gap on the first of
october will rise 12 percent which for a
typical home is a riser from
1130 quid to
1270 quid i say a typical home because
of course while it's called a price cap
that's a lie it is not a price cap it's
a rate cap it caps the rates that you
pay so if you use more you pay a lot
more we just give the the figure as a
price cap so people can understand it
based on typical use but there is no cap
on what you will pay if you use a lot
you'll pay a lot
so on the first of october that will go
up but what everybody needs to
understand is the first of october price
cap is based on average wholesale prices
in the six months until the end of july
when they were rising but they were not
rising astronomically
we are now in the assessment period for
the next price cap its six monthly which
happens on the 1st of april 2022
that period is from the 1st of august
this year
until the end of january
next year so we're roughly a third of
the way through that period and this is
the point where we have seen
astronomical rises in wholesale rates
now cornwall uh uh industry analysts who
are the people who look at the price cap
i got a figure from them yesterday that
at the current run rate the price next
april will go to 1
455 pounds on typical use which is
another 14 rise on top of the current
price cap and as people factor their
energy bills over the next year you need
to be aware of that and some have said
to me and again
yesterday
i got someone to put the question to
quasi quote saying about you know what's
going to happen april and he said nobody
knows what the what the energy price
will be in april well actually you've
got a pretty bloody good clue because
we're too a third of the way through the
analysis period for the next price cap
and if you look at where we are right
now wholesale prices would have to drop
to pandemic lows for the whole of the
remaining four months of this assessment
period
in order for the price cap not to rise
next april and most people think price
is going to stay pretty high for a good
deal longer
so while it may be temporary i think
this is certainly what's happening right
now is going to affect people's energy
bills for the next 12 months at least
and that is a real problem the price cap
right now is protective because
effectively it's forcing energy
companies to supply energy at below cost
but if the wholesale price drops next
april it will be destructive because it
will lock people in at a far higher
price than the market rates the time lag
here is a real problem and i've only
talked about the price cap if we look at
those people who are on cheap deals
they are now paying if your cheap fix is
coming to an end the cheapest fixes
available today are 60 percent higher
than what was available last year 60
if you were paying a grand a year you're
now going to be paying the equivalent of
1600 pounds a year on the same usage so
nobody's going to be doing that they're
all going to be moving to the price cap
and of course
all of this is without discussing the
huge market failure that means unless
something is done it's likely the vast
majority of energy firms in this country
are going to go bust leaving us with
primarily only the old monopoly
suppliers
now just sticking with consumers for now
and we're talking about the energy price
cap one of the things ministers are
really worried about is a cost of living
crisis going into the autumn in the
winter
but we've heard ministers talking about
this idea that the price cap is here to
stay the energy price can remain in
place and i think it's meant to offer
reassurance but
as you were explaining martin even if
you have the price cap that isn't going
to protect you from your bills going up
is that correct consumers are still
going to feel this
no the price cap is damage limitation
everybody is going to pay more for
energy than they were doing apart from
those people who locked into a long fix
you know a year or two ago and they went
by the two or three year fix which is a
very very small proportion of the
population
so everybody will pay more the question
is how much more the price cap does for
the next six months protect people from
being hit by the huge rise in wholesale
gas prices that's happening right now
but most people will then have to pay it
from the following april until the next
october which luckily is a slightly
lower use period but bills then are
going to be astronomically high if
people don't switch now when you couple
that with the end of the universal
credit uplift the end of furlough
support for some the end of
self-employment support for others and
the rate of inflation then it is not
hyperbole to say there are some people
in this country hopefully not many who
will have to choose between heating and
eating and the figure i like to bring in
when i talk about this is is the thing
that is meant to protect vulnerable
people from energy prices and the the
system is not one i would design but
that's what's in place
is the warm home discount
now the warm home discount is a 140
pound payment
that energy suppliers have to provide to
customers who are vulnerable in certain
categories and the categories can be
quite complicated
however
the warm home discount has been
140 pounds for the last
nine
years
in the last year alone the cheapest
energy deals have gone up by 60 percent
the price cap has gone up by 12
it's likely it will go up by another 14
next april the warm home discount is not
close to being enough to protect people
from what's going on in energy so what
we will need is we need the government
to increase the warm home discount but
of course it's energy suppliers who pay
the warm home discount and they are
currently
because of the price cap having to
supply energy deals at below cost so
there has to be a form of government
intervention here to say it's all going
to get better to say it's all temporary
i think ignores the real prosaic
problems that people will have paying
bills this winter
and
we've covered uh i suppose how consumers
are going to be affected by this um the
energy price cap but the other thing is
we are seeing energy companies saying
their risk of going bust um that they
need help
from the government
if
we do see these companies go bust what
happens to the customers at that point
well we have the off-gen safety net
which guarantees that if your company
goes bust you will be ported to a new
company and your credit will be
protected i'm not saying it's without
hassle and without difficulties but your
supply stays on and you're protected but
i'm not an economist i'm not a business
expert i'm a consumer finance journalist
so to my lack of knowledge and logic
about how this works i do find the
government stands a little bit confusing
because what it has said is
we will not
bail out companies who have failing
business models i understand that and i
understand the statement
instead the way it's looking at the
moment is the government is pushing
companies to provide energy at below
their cost
according to the price cap because
clearly wholesale rates now are higher
than the new price cap that comes in on
the first of october
so
to argue that it's a failing business
model when they're having to provide
energy at substantially below cost i
think it's quite tough because the only
ones who've got the capital to balance
that out are the huge former monopoly
suppliers
and so what is going to happen is
a lot of firms are going to go bust
people keep talking small firms it's not
small firms i mean there are companies
with over a million customers who may
well go under and are looking at
bringing in administrators this is
pretty much all firms but the main
former monopoly suppliers if the
wholesale prices stay where they are and
of course they could drop but nobody
knows when nobody knows by how much
so what does that mean the next result
of that is
it won't prop up failing business
suppliers in which case those customers
will have to be ported to the former
monopoly suppliers but they're not going
to take them on and going to take the
credit liabilities on because they're
having to supply below cost so the
government is going to have to foot up
and bail out the former monopoly
suppliers to take on the customers of
the small suppliers now
you know
if we take the government's ideology not
necessarily mine the government's
ideology has always been about promoting
competition in the energy market but
what we're about to see happen is small
companies mid-sized companies and some
larger companies go bust their customers
ported to the form of monopoly suppliers
who are going to be paid and bailed out
to take them i don't see how that fits
with a competition
a competition-paced policy and i just
think it's not very joined up at the
moment we are in a short-term crisis if
you want a competitive market which is
what the government has always said i'm
not sure they've managed it the right
way but if you're going to take the idea
that we run on a competitive market
you're going to need some competitors
yes i accept some of these small firms
have have crap business models and
should go by the wayside but not all of
them who are struggling are in that
position this is an unprecedented
crisis in wholesale prices hitting the
uk
far worse than any other countries i'm
not going to go into the reasons why the
uk is far worse hit i'll leave that for
the politicians i'm sure there are
people on lots of different sides of the
debate who will argue why it's happened
here but there is no doubt the uk is in
a radically different position to
anywhere else in europe and anywhere
else in the wholesale costs of energy in
this country and the government's going
to have to step in and do something one
way or another but it's got a question
what the end result of the market it'll
leave if what it effectively does is
just give money to the former monopoly
suppliers
thank you martin
now to covert histories of the pandemic
are already being written even though
we're still living through it kate
andrews reviews adam twos's shutdown in
this week's magazine and she joins me
now to discuss how we look at the
economy after coronavirus
with kate is the economist steve keane
an honorary professor at university
college london
kate steve thanks for joining us
kate the first draft of covid history is
starting to be written so what's the
verdict on our economic response
well in adam hughes's shutdown
he meticulously traces many different
elements of the surreal economic crash
that we saw at the height of the covet
crisis and then what governments around
the world did uh to combat the
consequences of that um there's some
spectacular little details in there um
stats uh about social distancing he
estimates that roughly 19 percent of
virus cases um were were mitigated
because of mandatory social distancing
from government the rest was down to
voluntary social distance saying really
interesting stats about men and women in
work and the ways that that looks very
different and what happened from the
financial crash of 2008
but overall it's a very difficult
and uphill challenge let's say to write
uh the history of coven 19 while it's
still taking place um you know our
battle with the virus isn't over it's
quite clear that adam twos had to stop
writing before we got to a lot of the
vaccine success um which i think does
change the narrative for a lot of
countries um so i mean a very lofty goal
to to set out the history of of cover 19
and the economic consequences of it but
very very difficult to do while that
story uh is still unfolding
steve what do you make so far i suppose
bigger picture of the economic response
to covet as kate mentions uh the slight
issue of these histories as things do
move quite quickly and vaccines have
transformed things
yeah it's it's you know we know that in
terms of scale of the downturn it why
far exceeds the great depression the
biggest downturn we've had in 300 years
and
the reason it was so severe was of
course it meant we couldn't do what is
essential for commerce and that is
connect
so
in that situation if we had only a
market economy response quite possibly
the market economy would have crashed
completely
people would have had financial
commitments they couldn't make for rent
for mortgages
banks could have folded dramatically so
there was a need when the when the
market system couldn't provide the money
there was a need for the government to
do it now that was done to some degree
and quite a substantial degree you see
the scale of the deficits that were
undertaken of the order of 30 and 40
percent of gdp which is comparable to
the deficits that funded the world world
war ii efforts uh so the governments did
well in one sense but less than they
should have done and the fact that
governments didn't provide sufficient
funding for people to not be forced to
go to work in the gig economy and so on
i think is one reason why the spread
was as far large as it was and the
violent reaction to the lockdown was as
bad as they were
it's all very well to be locked in if
you're like me where you have an
independent income if you're locked in
where the only way you can pay the
renters if you go out i can understand
that losing to riots around the world so
we did reasonably but i think i think
overall the
uh the effect of what we've done has
given us a virus we have to live with
for decades now which if we'd done a a
seriously well coordinated lockdown like
bernie yada yama suggested from the very
outset the man who was responsible for
blocking the ebola outbreak in 2014.
this would have been over in
ideally 12 weeks uh certainly seriously
half a year instead we're going to live
it for
for years if not decades
kate do you agree with that is that
would that have been a feasible option
uh i'm not sure i do i mean the broad
consensus is that um whether you had
locked down harder or faster or not
covet is now going to be one of the
viruses that we have to live with um
indefinitely
and thanks to the miraculous vaccines
which have been provided through a lot
of market forces no doubt there has been
um state and and private uh the private
sector working together on this but with
the incredible development that we've
seen in the private sector it is
something we can now realistically live
with um but look i i think there's
there's no doubt that the government is
there for these emergency times right
when it is the case that we have to do
something that is so unhuman so foreign
to us to lock ourselves away to not
interact with others to not engage in
commerce then you obviously if you're
going to force people to do that have to
bring in the support behind it countries
like the uk think we're very generous
with the furlough scheme quite literally
the government paying private sector
wages so people didn't have to go to
work but the difficult reality
is that whether it was
you mentioned the gig economy but
whether it's people who are doing
deliveries through amazon whether it's
people who are stacking shelves in
supermarkets whether it's doctors and
nurses still going to work there was
never going to be any scenario where
everyone could truly have gone home for
12 weeks every single person without
i mean causing probably far more pain
frankly than the virus would have caused
the amount of deaths that could have
been caused by the shortages by the lack
of health care uh would have far
outpaced what we actually witnessed from
the virus i think we have a candidate of
that and that's new zealand uh which
before delta was brought in uh just
recently uh successfully did that uh so
with with a with a successful you know
social compact which were new zealand
has far better than uh europe uh america
the uk australia
um they managed to suppress the virus
completely on three separate codes still
they still had doctors and nurses in
their hospitals though they still had
people stacking the shelves in
supermarkets not everybody was home as
you suggested no no i'm not saying
everybody should be home and saying it
should be essential workers who are
allowed to travel and deliver goods to
the rest of us
and they should be vaccinated as soon as
possible on this fan for example i was
vaccinated first in march of 2020
okay 2020. the reason being i know
vaccine researchers who gave me a
vaccine shot
in advance you can develop the vaccines
this rapidly now one case i'll certainly
agree with you the regulation got in the
way is the regulations we have for
vaccines are designed for the mass
distribution vaccines that have to be
tested because they have so many
potentially bad side effects vaccines
can now be developed in a matter of days
after we first decode a genome and if
we'd done that for essential workers
right from the very outset
knowing this is a pandemic not something
which is you know as slow as a disease
which is already there it's a new one we
could have uh isolated the the frontline
workers right in the very outset allowed
them to travel because they were now
safe and kept the others indoors until
this thing was defeated
so it's potentially it's possible to do
a combination about lockdowns and and
ring fencing with vaccines at three
levels that could have controlled this
and the fact that we haven't done it as
a sign of how unprepared we've been by
the focus upon efficiency for the last
25 years because the first warning we
got about this being a likelihood back
in 1995 uh with garrett's uh the coming
plague
now
just looking back to i suppose the focus
on the economy um i just wanted
kate do you think that if we're looking
at the response to covert do you think
it's changed the way that people look at
the economy and the role of the
government in this as you say you know
mass bailout and the fact that
in a way
magic money tree arguments are harder to
make after you go through something like
this
well certainly uh i think we're moving
into an era of a bigger state especially
in the west you can see that countries
run by parties that traditionally are on
the right that might support more market
mechanisms they've even changed their
narrative and they seem to think that
more state intervention is necessary
this is going to catch up with us very
quickly though if we continue to operate
as if it's emergency times if we
continue to spend like it's emergency
times you do have a few uh politicians
here in the uk the chancellor included
who are very worried about the
inflationary risks who realize that it's
going to become more and more difficult
to service our debt even if inflation
and interest rates go up by say one
percent and they're preparing for that
and you only have to look this week in
the uk at the energy crisis that we're
witnessing to see how quickly situations
can change and how costs can um
skyrocket and how we can be ill-prepared
so i think it's going to be a painful
process of weaning people off those
emergency measures an important one
although i don't think we'll go the full
way i do think we're probably uh in for
a a decade's worth of larger states at
least until those arguments for market
mechanisms are are made again um i think
you can point to every country in this
crisis and point out good times and bad
times for most of them and that's the
crazy thing about this virus is that at
some point countries are up at other
points they're down mistakes have been
made everywhere along the way and and
the uk you know they did at the height
of the first crisis make it clear that
only essential workers could go out um
to steve's point you know those vaccines
were not available and we can talk about
the regulations around vaccines some
other time um but now we've got
countries like new zealand who are
really behind on their vaccine roll out
and who are finding it much harder to
open up when here in the uk many
most of the restrictions are now lifted
and this is going to have real economic
impact in the years to come the oecd has
recently released their new set of
forecasts and the uk does look like its
economic bounce back amongst developed
countries is going to be one of the best
still so many things could change this
we're going into a tough winter there's
already talk of restrictions coming back
it's really again back to adam tuce's
book it's really hard to write the
history of this uh before the story is
actually over but there's no doubt that
there are going to be major consequences
to what we did shutting down the world's
economy and having it spring back like
this um a lot of people because of that
emergency support might think that we've
got out of this consequence free it's
just not going to be the case for years
now we're going to learn of all that
happened when these economies were shut
down all the pain psychological physical
um
all of it that it caused um and we're
gonna have to try to uh remedy that
through a lot of public policy that
we're gonna have to craft quite quickly
i mean on that public policy uh one
example of how we weren't thinking
properly about pandemics before this
struck uh was that i've forgotten the
actual minister responsible for this but
there was a task force in the uk
directed to find out how many masks
should be in the national reserve and
the advice coming back to the expert
committee was about a billion now the
reaction to municipal that's too many
let's have 50 million what that meant
was in one day you exhausted your your
ration of masks uh so the obsession with
efficiency and cutting costs uh you know
the economizing of government spending
literally made this substantially worse
than it could have been and the
obsession with running a balanced budget
uh the belief that government should run
surpluses that is actually rather than
preparing us for a rainy day that took
the roof off the house before a rainy
day so i think a huge change we should
learn the lesson we've learned here
governments can spend whatever they wish
when there's an emergency and when they
fund it the funding is actually not uh
borrowing from the public the deficit
creates money for the public it creates
money the banks use to buy the bonds
that is then financed so there's no
failure about the government doing it
the problems are the effect inflationary
ones kate mentioned also of course we're
tracking now the supply chain
disruptions which according causing
supply
cost pressure that we've never had
before and to that that extent we have
to say well globalization may have made
us more fragile so we have to look at
building a more robust
economic structure not one obsessed with
efficiency but looking at robustness as
well and that means having slack which
has to be paid for not by the private
sector but by the public
and steve just finally i wanted to end
this by talking about the economic
recovery now do you think this uh is
actually going to be faster than many uh
anticipated obviously you heard a lot
about the v i think the uh success of
lockdowns meant that uh that that failed
to come to pass but with vaccines
actually we will move past um i suppose
the the damage done by covid to the
economy quickly because people can
rebound particularly in countries with
fast vaccine roulettes
compared to a normal
drop breakdown which is caused by a
credit crunch which is what happened
back in 2008 yes it will be faster
and
you haven't got a collapsing credit
based demand driving this uh which was
the failure to recognize that and then
running austerity after particularly in
the case of the uk is why the recovery
took so long from 2008. this time we do
have you know pent-up spending power uh
pressures we have the public with a
large surplus and their accounts go to
see if the large deficit the government
has run so there is more cash for the
private sector to spend and i think at
some extent uh what happened back after
the spanish flu may well happen again as
long as it can and that is a lot of
people say the roaring 20s was a
response to being
stuck in the lockdowns of the spanish
flu so yes there will be more potential
for that but i don't i think this is
just a prelude to what climate change is
going to do us i wouldn't be uh putting
on my dancing shoes just yet
kate steve thanks for coming on
now finally cambridge university's vice
chancellor stephen tupe has announced
that he'll be standing down for his
position in september 2022
in this announcement he said i take a
great deal of pride in our
accomplishments which were built
together as a collegiate cambridge
community but at the same time the
upheaval of covert has led me to
reassess my own years ahead from a
personal perspective being near my own
family and friends is more important
than ever
so what will his legacy be douglas
murray writes for the spectator's
website this week that his time in the
post had been an unmitigated disaster
to explain douglas joins me now
um douglas thank you for coming on today
stephen troop has resigned so what do
you think is really behind it
um well um the vice chancellor of
cambridge has said that he is going to
step down early from his tenure because
he wants to spend more time with his
family
which
may be the case uh
it's a rather
famous infamous cop-out phrase normally
certainly in in british politics people
say they want to spend more time with
their families when they know no one
else wants to spend time with them
generally um
but yes so that's his claim uh it's very
unlikely to be true uh stephen tube's
tenure at cambridge has been marred by a
whole set of controversies
uh uh battles within the university and
indeed with the wider culture
that have mattered very much and steven
tooth has been losing these battles one
by one
uh he's brought an enormous amount of
negative attention to cambridge
university uh um most observers have
recognized that his tenure in position
has been absolutely lamentable
and uh so i think it's rather obvious
you don't really need to read putting
the lines to come to this conclusion
that he's leaving because he's no good
at the job and everyone knows it
and what about china do you think that
uh that has played a role in his demise
uh this is very interesting uh the
spectator of course we ran a cover piece
about this uh just a couple of months
ago um about the extraordinary way in
which stephen tupes uh period in
cambridge has coincided with an amazing
amount of sucking up to the authorities
in china for funding
and more and uh our cover piece which
exposed that
uh uh was um was not able to be refuted
by cambridge university uh a few
lackluster attempts to try it uh but
nobody could deny the facts i mean they
start from the fact that very shortly
after his tenure began at cambridge
university stephen two went straight to
the chinese embassy and had his
photographs taken and talked about the
importance of greater cooperation
between the authorities in china and
educational institutions in the uk such
as his own um cambridge during his
tenure
took significant amounts of funding from
chinese
government
linked organizations and backers and uh
there are many many reports as we laid
out in our cover piece of academics and
others who saw that this was a complete
uh um completely contrary to a
university's interests and that the
involvement of the chinese authorities
in cambridge
clearly compromised free academic
inquiry it was an extraordinary
misjudgment stephen tube couldn't defend
it and i think it's certainly one of the
reasons why he's going
are you hopeful then that although the
successor has not yet been appointed we
could start to see actually a reversal
when it comes to the university's
approach to dealing with china
uh i would certainly hope so what
stephen tupe's tenure at cambridge uh um
shows is something wider just than the
china question though see what's so
striking about it
is that a vice chancellor of a british
university should be sucking up to the
communist party of china uh at the same
time as instituting a whole set of new
speech codes himself or trying to uh
within cambridge university uh
stephen two forever talked
during his tenure about
academic freedom whilst overseeing the
trashing of it as i said on the
spectator online this week
his tenure for instance coincided with
the sacking of a young academic called
noah carl from one of cambridge's
colleges
purely because a mob of completely
uninformed students claimed that carl's
research was in some way racist and he
was fired and that was overseen by two
that was a complete uh um
demolition
of the principle of academic freedom uh
whereby mobs cannot simply turn up
outside colleges and demand the firing
of people whose research they don't
understand
more infamously perhaps stephen two
oversaw and defended
the very ignominious firing of a better
canadian than himself uh professor
jordan peterson
who a few years ago was meant to have
taken up a visiting professorship
that is a non-paying
fellowship at cambridge for a term in
the theology faculty and that invitation
was rescinded by the authorities at
cambridge when it was discovered that at
a meet and greet after an event one of
the thousands of people who jordan
peterson had been photographed
standing beside was somebody wearing a
t-shirt that said i'm a proud
islamophobe and for standing beside
somebody with a t-shirt that's
controversial
uh stephen tupe uh said yes it's correct
that this man should john peterson uh
should have his offer of a visiting
fellowship removed so
there were very strange rules that were
going on in his time uh perhaps it might
also be said uh that he oversaw uh other
types of controversy in cambridge um
without being able to manage them either
um
there are quite a lot that i list in the
spectator online um that show that
actually stephen tube in his tenure at
cambridge had very little understanding
of academic freedom which is perhaps why
he found the chinese authorities so um
amenable
and just finally douglas the government
has been looking at things like a
freedom of speech bill which could see
when it comes to campuses fines or
sanctions for those who are in breach of
it do you think that could be a useful
tool or is that the wrong approach
it could be i'm slightly skeptical about
it i'm rather skeptical of the concept
of the free speech tsar and other such
things i mean whoever it is would have
to be um purer than
mother teresa or gandhi or or anyone
else
i don't think such a person will be able
to be found or agreed upon um so i am
slightly skeptical of the government's
actual proposals whilst um
lording the the the principles behind
them um it just it just has to be
stressed that the the universities must
be places
for free inquiry at the very highest
level
they must be places of robust debate and
discussion and discovery
and they should not be
able to be treated like the sort of
nursery gardens that they have been uh
in recent uh years
so i very much hope that the situation
does change at cambridge but there's one
final point i might make on this which
is that it's very important i think for
people to realize one lesson that should
be taken from all of this
uh
occasionally people have said why are
you so invested in in this issue of
cambridge university's vice chancellor
and it isn't just as i say because it
seems to me to matter very much that our
institutions aren't taken over by people
who are unworthy and unfit for them but
also because it's very important that
people realize that when you get sort of
whitmer pool like bureaucrats like
tube
it's very important that people realize
that they largely succeed because they
parrot and then get ahead of the
particular dogmas of the era and then
punish people who aren't parroting
exactly the dogmas and people like to uh
rise up in public life and take over
institution after institution because
they keep ahead of that lamentable curve
and they think that there's only
something to gain
from doing so and for them in the short
term that might be correct they collect
salaries of hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of pounds a year they benefit
very nicely from it but what i suggest
is that people see that as well as
people being able to benefit from
getting ahead of this i think lamentable
curve there are also dangers from doing
so and there are um punishments indeed
for doing so i think that's that toop
should be seen to be a moral
a moral story there it's one of the
things that happens
when you try to make people who are
smarter than you
uh follow through on dumb ideas and dumb
dogmas
one of the things that can happen from
that is that people will rebel you will
actually be chucked out or effectively
be forced to leave your job there is a
downside to being too woke as well as an
upside
douglas thanks for coming on
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel so you
never miss an episode again just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video
and then the bell icon
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you